اطباء مصر لا يشعرون بالانصاف هكذا يقول
من هاجر منهم الى بريطانيا فهم تركوا
قطاعا صحيا قالوا انه ياخذوا منهم اكثر
مما يعطيهم لا ماديا فقط وانما معنويا
وذهنيا الدكتور مصطفى عبد الله والدكتوره
هند الديب من بين اكثر من 11 الف طبيب
مصري غادروا قطاع الصحه في مصر ما بين
و2022 وفقا لنقابه الاطباء المصريه
ساعات عمل طويله اللايف ورك بلانس او
الموازنه بين العمل وبين الحياه طبعا صعب
شويه وطبعا مشكله كبيره جدا في مصر في
مجال الطبي الحكومي هي الفلوس وده برضو من
احد اسباب كبيره جدا اغلبيه الناس اللي
موجوده في انجلترا مصريين بيجوا عشان
يطلعوا من هذه المشكله ويجوا البلد ثانيه
احنا شايفينها بنحترم اكتر الاطباء
وبتديهم فلوس انوف او تديهم
يعني او تقدير من حيث مادي او معنوي او او
احترام عامه في الشغل عامه من عشره 15 سنه
برده احنا مكناش على التواصل مع الدكاتره
دول تانيه فكنا فاكرين ان ده الطبيعي
اه كنا عارفين ان في امريكا وفي انجلترا
وفي الدول
عندهم نظام احسن مننا كثير بس اللي
اكتشفناه ان لا حتى في دول جيران دينا في
افريقيا واسيا عندهم ترينينج احسن مننا
بمراحل وعندهم او بتاعهم كمان احسن مننا
فجاه بدانا نفوق لان لا
الوضع مش كل الدول والدول دي مش هتحل لينا
اقتصاديا في الحلقه الاقتصاديه وفي الحاله
التعليميه وفي كل حاجه طب ليه العديد من
الاطباء المصريين وجدوا في بريطانيا مكانا
لتحقيق احلامهم المهنيه سمعنا الاسباب
التي جاءوا من اجلها وروايه وصولهم الى
هنا لكن القصه لا تبدا من هنا تبدا من
هناك من مصر وزميلنا احمد عثمان سيروي لنا
هذه القصه من هناك
بالفعل متى حدث به عدد من الاطباء
المصريين المقيمين في لندن يمثل واقع
المؤلما لعشرات الالاف من الاطباء
المصريين
كريم حسين احد هؤلاء الحالمين بالتوجه
للعاصمه البريطانيه متخرج منذ خمسه اعوام
ومتخصص في مجال الكبد دخله الشهري من
العمل في المستشفى الحكومي 4000 ومئتي اي
ما يقرب من 150 دولارا اغلب الاطباء
بيفكروا له جات لهم فرصه ان هو يسافر ولكن
ده مش هروبا من من اداء الخدمه الطبيه في
مصر ولكن بيبقى بحث للتعليم الطبي ان هو
يسافر يتعلم افضل يلاقي فرص تعليم طبيه
افضل بره نفسه الاملي يسيطر على اجيال
اكبر احمد بيومي المتخصص في مجال علم
النفس تخرج منذ 13 عاما يركز حاليا على
استكمال دراسه الزماله البريطانيه
استعدادا للرحيل الرغبه دايما في عالم
البحث عن عالم جديد يكون في واجبات واضحه
حقوق واضحه نسبه التعدي على اطباء اللي
ظهرت في المستشفيات اثناء ازمه كورونا
وفيما بعد قبلها وفيما بعدها يؤدي الى
نزوح كتير او تفكير كتير من الاطباء في
الى الخارج للتحصيل العلمي والاستلام
والبحث عن الامان الانساني والاماني
المادي ايضا نقابه الاطباء حذرت من
تداعيات هذا النزوح الكبير ده انذار كبير
جدا جدا وخطوره كبيره جدا ولازم انبه ان
مش زياده عدد الطلاب ودخول طلاب كليات
الطب هيبقى هو الحل زياده عدد وخريجي
كليات الطب سيؤدي الى زياده عدد الهجره
لابد من حل التلات اسباب اللي بيؤدي
الهجره الاطباء التدريب والتعليم الطبي
المستمر بيئه العمل المناسبه ودخل الاطباء
وقد تكون ازمه هجره الاطباء رساله جاده
للدوله بضروره سرعه اعتماد رؤيه جديده
للحفاظ على مستقبل مصر من الاطباء احمد
عثمان العربيه القاهره